before we start going to take care of a
few housekeeping details first of all as
you can see c-span is here today so if
you want to tell your friends about
Richard Zacks talk it will be posted it
will be up on the book TV website in
about five days you can you can watch it
when it comes up when they schedule it
on c-span or you can also watch it on
the book TV website and today because
c-span is over here I think we just have
one microphone for questions
okay so what yeah the one microphone for
questions is over here so if audience if
audience would please go to the
microphone forward to ask your questions
then we can we can get you on the camera
and we can get you on the audio tape as
well so okay I'm Barbara Bude I'm one of
the founders of politics and prose and
this is a real treat for me to come in
and introduce Richard Zacks who's
written his new book hold on a second
called chase chasing the last laugh it
has a wonderful subtitle Mark Twain's
raucous and redemptive round-the-world
comedy tour and I tell you it was just a
great deal of fun to read it when I was
having so much fun reading it I thought
well I bet the author had even more fun
writing it because you can you can just
tell that he Richard Sachs had was
having a good time
Richard Sachs was born in that Center of
Gothic pleasure Savannah and so maybe
that says a little bit about his
attraction to the life and writing of
Mark Twain by his own description he
grew up having fun growing dabbling in
life's darker pleasures alcohol
all cursing gambling betting on horses
and playing blackjack in Manhattan's
illegal card parlors so it comes as no
surprise that Richard felt in
identification with Mark Twain who also
loved darker pleasures but Mark Twain
also craved high high brow respect
Richard saw his high brow respect by
majoring in classical Greek at the
University of Michigan and receiving his
graduate degree in journalism at the
Columbia School of Journalism and then
after a spell of writing for newspapers
he went on to do something that what can
you do more respectable than writing
books and he has written a number of
them since then he had this time by this
time he sold over 500,000 copies of his
books they've been translated into
Spanish Korean Chinese Japanese and
finished but most important odd if you
want to earn respect
there's critical praise and that's
exactly what richard has piled up the
marks between journal describes his new
book as impossible to put down with
fresh information about episodes and
Twain's life on every page the Kirkus
Reviews as it offers a frolicking of
rollicking history perfect for Twain's
countless fans and Publishers Weekly who
gave it a starred review called it
deeply enter deeply entertaining account
wealth research with rich detail and
then Richard I want to say one last
thing before you talk and that is that I
hope that your identification with Mark
Twain extends to the rest of your life
as well because that Mark Twain at the
end of his life after
are spending a good deal of time badly
in debt fending off creditors he died
with a net worth in today's dollars of
15 million dollars so here's to Richard
Zacks having the saiga
[Applause]
okay that was most of my speech but I
have a little bit left thank you
so ya ready for the first okay um
everybody can see the slide it's pretty
clear thank you so much for coming
there's so many different people from
different parts of my life feels a
little like a wake but a little
premature hopefully so here we go jump
right into it here is Mark Twain at
breakfast in Olympia Washington August
1895 don't you love that hair I am so
jealous so I want to tell you about the
Mark Twain and not everybody knows about
most people think of this witty author
of Huckleberry Finn who fought racism
and imperialism that's all true but he
was also an eternal bad boy he liked to
drink smoke and curse he married an
heiress who paid the bills but he loved
to gamble on pool and poker and
unfortunately for him on startup
companies and all these traits
eventually caught up with them I mean
can you imagine being the comedy kingpin
of the United States and at age 60
losing it all I mean he was dead broke
in 1895 and he had lost all his money
and all his wife's money and I just
can't imagine losing all my wife's money
I mean the thought it so terrifies me
she's sitting it there are torture
implements that haven't been invented
that she would use on me so after a
while the family the family of Samuel
Clemens could no longer afford to live
in their own beautiful home I mean how
sad is that
and they had it's a quirky wonderful
house I mean he designed it himself in a
large extent he had a fireplace built
with a win
go over it so the smoke would go on
either side and he could see snow
falling while the flames are coming up
he adored this house and they had a
happy loopy family life they had three
dogs and Twain named one I know
another dog you know and the third dog
was don't know he also enjoyed acting
with his daughter Suzy they were rich
they had a Tiffany drawing-room the
family had seven servants including a
butler and a coachman but it was never
enough for Twain the poor Missouri boy
wanted everything he wanted to be a
funny writer but also to be a literary
author he wanted to be a family man but
he also wanted to be a poker playing
rogue he was so full of conflicting
desires he liked down-home folk and he
also wanted to be rich as a Rockefeller
or a Vanderbilt he wrote few of us can
stand prosperity another man's I mean
and he was a magnet for con men what a
talker he is hero to the inventor James
W page he could persuade a fish to come
out and take a walk with him so Twain
was losing his shirt he had a lethal
combination for an investor moonshot
enthusiasm and no patience for details
he once asked an accountant to send him
a profit loss statement that even his
daughter could understand Jean was 2
years old at the time so Twain thought
the following invention would change the
world you don't recognize it this is the
page typesetter weighed almost 4 tons
18,000 moveable parts and it was
supposed to revolutionize pub printing
if it worked
now Twain had the immense misfortune of
seeing it work once at first Twain
called James page the quote Shakespeare
of mechanical invention by the end after
kept breaking down Twain began
fantasizing about capturing a certain
part of Paige's Anatomy in a steel trap
and watching him slowly bleed to death
so the page typesetter cleaned out
Twain's bank account this next
investment starting his own publishing
company put him eighty thousand dollars
or the equivalent of 2.4 million in
modern currency in debt
they started off incredibly well they
published grants memoirs and enormous
success and Huckleberry Finn and Twain
expected to pay himself at royalties he
wound up receiving no royalties this is
their final list of titles and I don't
know if you can see from there but any
publisher that's going to go out with
stories from the rabbi's it's probably
going to be in a little trouble
so headlines it was deeply humiliating
headlines of the newspapers said Mark
Twain fails I mean it was brutal no joke
failure of Mark Twain failure of
humorist and he's this literary
superstar deeply embarrassed and he gets
two main advisors for his bankruptcy one
is Henry Huddleston Rodgers HH one of
the wealthiest men in America the
right-hand man to john d rockefeller
Standard Oil federal steel his nickname
was hellhound and this robber baron
wants to play hardball with the
creditors he wants to offer ten cents on
the dollar
Twain's other advisor is his wife Livy
she has absolutely no business
experience she writes him I want the
creditors to know that we have their
interests at heart
much much more than our own Livi living
when we have some bankruptcy experts in
the crowd here look Livy wanted to pay
them in full as soon as possible well a
word of advice never bet against the
wife twain agreed to pay everyone back
in full and so he needs to make big
money fast and his books are not selling
his most recent title was the american
claimant not exactly a huge seller so
the quickest way for him to make money
is to go out on a stand-up comedy tour
and he absolutely from the bottom of his
heart
did not want to go it's a little-known
fact that Mark Twain dreaded public
speaking in front of large audiences but
it wasn't so much stage fright as
humiliation fright he did not want to
play the clown he thought of himself as
a literary author and he said to a
friend that once an audience sees you
stand on your head they'll expect you to
remain in that position forever so his
performing style with deadpan never
smiled talked slow and he borrowed lines
from his stories pretty pretty wonderful
lines like the weather was too rainy for
school and just rainy enough to go
fishing or to be good as Noble to teach
others to be good as nobler and no
trouble
so it's July 1895 he's 59 years old he's
about to go out on the road with his
wife and daughter three creditors are
suing him stress has given him an
infected boil on his thigh he can't walk
he wants to do a dozen warm-up speeches
but he only has time for two he wrote to
hell hound nothing in this world can
save it from being a poor shabby
disgusting performance pray for me so
Twain sets out on this trip he'd be gone
a year he would do 122 performances in
71 cities across the US and the fading
British Empire in Australia New Zealand
India and South Africa it's an
exhausting trip even for a young man he
would spend 98 nights at sea and almost
50 days ill from coughs and other
illnesses he would travel by rail
rickshaw mule drawn carriage and by
elephants and his sightseeing boat would
wander close to the floating corpses in
the Ganges and Zulus would do war dances
for him in South Africa so first stop
Cleveland Ohio July 15 1895 a disaster
no one had told him that a pair of
newlyweds are going to perform 40
minutes of violin and flute music yeah
and then no one told them that 500
newsboys would be sitting behind him in
bleachers and there'd be no chaperone
Twain would later complained bitterly to
hellhound about all the quote horseplay
and skylarking which I have to admit I
find a little ironic from the creator of
Huckleberry Finn but anyhow Twain judged
this night a dead failure and described
the perspiring audience as paying a
dollar apiece
to go and to go to hell in this fashion
so the cross-country trip started
improving quickly and he started feeding
off off the audience's laughing clapping
and paying and Twain's lecture agent a
major James pond luckily for us brought
along a Kodak box camera and he wasn't a
very good photographer which is also
good he these are intimate looks not
really fancy publicity shots so here's
the first one here is Livie telling her
husband to put on an overcoat it was 98
degrees that day they had a great
marriage but a lot of it revolved around
Lily Livie telling him to mind his
manners
she called him youth forever she always
called him youth and most strangers by
the way called him mr. Clemens so Twain
tried really hard not to swear in front
of her and so the rest of us can drop
the occasional f-word or the occasional
damn Twain needed to be far more
creative and I truly think it helped his
writing I mean he talked about a saint
on ice and all this other stuff he had
to be more creative so they begin their
trek across the u.s. Twain's Cui's did a
little sightseeing I love this
photograph this is this is a Norwegian
shanty town outside Great Falls Montana
and it's an authentic tarpaper Shack and
see Twain's holding two kittens Twain
loved cats he often wore a family cat
draped around his neck and his daughter
Clara gave some sage advice she said if
you had to interrupt her father when he
was writing always carry a kitten
so later in the trip the family was
staying in a run-down hotel paper-thin
walls surly servants and Twain did not
sleep well he wrote in his notebook
early in the morn and a baby began
pleasantly didn't mind baby and the
piano played by either the cat or a
partially untrained artists most
extraordinary music 3 write notes to 4
wrong ones but played with eager zeal
old tunes of 40 years ago and
considering it was the cat 4 it must
have been the cat it was a really
marvelous performance it convinced me
that cat is more intelligent than people
believe so travelling long distances in
the 1890s no cars obviously so it meant
trains and since Twain was a celebrity
he got occasionally to ride up with the
engineer it's the Great Northern
Railroad but like the rest of us
sometimes he had to wait and here he is
in Crookston Minnesota they had arrived
at the station at 4:00 a.m. only to
discover a handwritten sign and said the
train would be an hour and 20 minutes
late and the night was chilly and Twain
lost it he erupted he yelled at his
agent he demanded at major pond honor
his contract and get him traveling so
here we have the nation's leading
lecture agent what 57 years old wheeling
Twain around the station in the middle
of the night and if you look carefully
Livie is like shading her eye she can't
even bear to look at her husband and
they were both living and Claire was so
appalled that Clara borrowed major ponds
camera to take the picture and that's
her shadow there and then would also I
love about this pictures there are 17
pieces of luggage if you count them up
and 7 steamer trunks they're going
around the world with 7 steamer trunks
you know travel in the 1890s Oh
Mark Twain would perform 22 nights and
31 days in North America and he went
from a sickbed in New York to a
breakneck schedule and back to aced oh
this is the wrong sorry back to a
sickbed in vancouver canada oh that
means there's going to be the wrong
slides at the end we'll just roll with
it
and I gotta think for a second okay
here is embedding you got to love that
hair he is suffering from a bad
bronchial cough you can see the pipe he
did several interviews in bed but being
a former newspaper man he knew that
newspaper men lied so he was nervous
about it and they'd ask in every town
the same question what will your travel
book be about and he'd go why my travels
I suppose and he got so sick of the
question he started tossing off answers
such as it'll be about hydrophobia
agriculture wallpaper so the family
departed August 23rd 1895 from Victoria
Canada for Australia Twain had survived
a grueling schedule he had made about
four thousand dollars which in modern
currencies about 120,000 but most of it
went to hotel and travel and dining
expenses because he was convinced that
his Aerith wife on the right deserved to
always stay in the most first-class
places and he bought first-class steamer
tickets that literally cost half of the
amount that he had earned lecturing so
Twain's holding a long stem pipe there
and he and major Pond had gone shopping
that morning he had bought five hundred
cigars and four pounds of tobacco for a
25 day voyage you can do the math he
could smoke about 20 cigars a day and
major pond later wrote a memoir and put
the number at 3,000 cigars Twain said
pond is not an interesting liar he is
destitute of the sense of proportion if
only his parents had taken the least
little pains with his training
so Mark Twain loved cruise ships
he's a former Mississippi riverboat
pilot not surprising and he threw
himself into card shuffleboard
stargazing whale watching he loved the
fact that you could not get newspapers
no Telegraph no telephone in that era it
was a remote oasis but back to those 500
cigars nothing was ever easy for Twain
on this voyage the captain decided to
strictly enforce the rules against
smoking yeah and so there we go the
strictly against the rules against
smoking and he wanted to smoke in his
stateroom he needed to smoke too right
and he had once tried giving up smoking
and had limit himself to one cigar a day
he found himself hunting up larger and
larger cigars within a month he wrote my
cigar grown to such proportions that I
could have used it as a crutch he gave
up the experiment so now on this ship
he'd have to go on deck in the rain in
the wind to smoke and he might have made
peace with those rules might have but
there was a little pug dog a little
Pekinese dog on that ship and Twain
wrote the dog was allowed to quote
discharge its inexhaustible bowels
anywhere on the ship and Twain vowed he
would break every rule on the ship until
the dog was reined in Twain had a
tendency to demonize enemies made in
dogs captain's business partners other
writers he said any ships library
containing no Jane Austen was good even
if it contained no books at all so as
the ship approached to Australia Twain
became worried about what his reception
would be there I mean would the British
Empire embrace an American you know
stand-up performance so here is Sydney
Australia 1895 and Twain arrives and he
made a very bold choice he decided he
would deliver a poem about Australia a
purposely dreadful poem an absolutely
excruciating poem and he would do it
eight-faced he would pick a national
animal for the Australians he decided
against the kangaroo or the koala he
chose the platypus he decided to use its
latin name Ornithorhynchus paradoxes he
said he wished he had named one of his
daughters that for those of you who
don't know the platypus is a duck-billed
cloth but a beaver tail degli an animal
literally neither fish nor fowl so Twain
had trouble finding rhymes for all the
body parts so he rearranged the beasts
said he needed the animal to cooperate
for them to have an accessor was
definitely better than the poem in fact
anything was better than that poem so it
was a huge hit down under and Twain was
just embraced in Australia he scored a
massive payday sold out all his shows
and major cities added more shows
thunderous ovations wealthy citizens
invited him to tea to dinners he went to
the racetrack and Australia gave him the
first glimmer of hope that he could pay
these debts next stop New Zealand after
Twain met his first Maori native it took
him only 15 minutes to decide that he
likes seeing tattooed faces and bodies
he found the designs quote flowing
graceful beautiful and then after
another 15 minutes he decided the
undecorated European face was a bit
unpleasant so New Zealand didn't have
too many large cities so 20 found time
for sightseeing and he liked to see
strange animals so he went to the
Natural History Museum in Christchurch
and he saw the giant MOA I love this you
know I mean if you can see that that is
the skeleton this is the actual skeleton
that Twain saw I mean he saw it in a
museum but this is the skeleton and the
giant MOA was an extinct giraffe like
bird only extinct about five hundred
years so Twain wondered why it had died
out and he learned there was a native
Maori expression as stupid as a giant
MOA
so Twain was fascinated and he wrote
about what he imagined it would feel
like to be kicked by this enormous bird
and his illustrator got a little carried
away
yeah dan beard and so you see the flying
head the geyser of blood and Twain love
Dan beards
illustrations because they were
subversive and Dan beard like to slip in
a little nudity sometimes so this is
actually a kind of quite creepy scene to
slip in nudity it's an Australian
Rancher was accused of feeding a poison
Christmas pudding to the local
Aborigines and if you look carefully you
can see wishing you a Merry Christmas
coming out of his pipe smoke so this is
a very dark image for nudity anyhow
Twain had a buddy for much of the trip
and this is 30 year old Carlisle Smythe
who's the son of Twain's
lecture agent and he shepherded Smythe
shepherded the the Clemens family for
nine months and played a lot of cards
and billiards with Twain and whenever
Smythe was winning Twain changed the
rules so now Twain was going to turn 60
on November 30th and he was a bit
obsessed with the loss of youth and gave
a speech and he said he thought God
should have considered cutting off the
entire human race at the age of 30
because everyone treasures their youth
and looks back on it longingly he said
quote old age has its own value but that
is to other people not to those who have
it yeah next stop India now to Wayne had
worked hard for six months but he had
earned only one-fifth of what he needed
and he also got sick again with another
chest cold but against all odds he
absolutely fell in love with India and
he stayed for two and a half months he
loved the colors closed dancing girls
turbans chaos years later he would call
India the own quote the only foreign
land I ever daydream about or deeply
longed to see again so he arrives in his
hotel in Bombay
and this is his view out the window he's
getting a snake-charmer
a juggler he loved the unpredictability
of India I have to admit I found this
slide and couldn't resist including and
I can't confirm the Twain saw this man
cross on this rope bridge but it's the
unpredictability of India and he was
amazed by how crowded the sidewalks were
holy Brahman Bulls Twain admired their
freedom to go anywhere and since he was
deeply in debt
he was quite jealous of the holy men the
[ __ ] who could just lie around and
receive donations all day so Twain
visited the holy city of Banaras today
Varanasi and he witnessed women bathing
in the holy Ganges and Twain was amazed
that the Hindu women were so adept at
spinning out of a wet sari and into a
dry one without revealing any bronze as
he put it and he also sounded a tad
annoyed about that
and see what's next and he did he did
see the the corpses and the funeral gods
as well I want to take you on a little
sightseeing moment with Mark Twain so he
wants to go to this mosque here in
Banaras pair of 142 foot tall slender
minarets he climbs the endless spiral
staircase gets to the top and this is a
typical sightseeing episode with the
holy city unfurled below he happened to
notice a gray monkey scampering over the
parapets making long leaps and Twain
wrote he got me so nervous that I
couldn't look at the view the monkey
came within an ace of losing his life a
dozen times and I was so troubled about
him that I would have shot him if I had
anything to do with it so in India Twain
found himself again and again having to
confront his opinions of another
person's religion and he decided that
one couldn't be expected to believe
another man's beliefs but he should
respect them and he also judged it wrong
for missionaries to try and impose their
beliefs on someone else he wrote in his
notebook that he had heard that
Christian missionaries had achieved
little success converting
Hindus but that they had scored some
breakthroughs with monkeys he wrote
quote in two years at a cost of $60,000
for monkeys converted and 11 hopefully
interested so while in India Mark Twain
received one of the most amazing perks
well he also rode an elephant while in
India then he wrote another elephant and
another elephant ah this is a different
version of the slide it's all good he
received one of the most amazing perks
that I think any celebrity has ever been
granted we're not talking courtside
seats or free bottles of champagne
British railway officials set aside 35
miles of track in the Himalayas for Mark
Twain to use as a private roller coaster
so here is it Darjeeling 7,000 foot
elevation and this is near Mount Everest
so these are not clouds these are
snow-capped peaks
I mean Twain is up in the Himalayas and
this is such a steep area that the
railway needed to use for reverse
zigzags we're literally car reverses
direction in order to deal with the
steepness and also for horizontal loops
like this one so no seatbelts are
mentioned a six-seater open car gravity
would propel them downward and only a
handbrake could stop them as Twain
pointed out to his wife and daughter an
unseen pebble on the track might derail
them at a curve on February 17th 1896
they zoomed downward starting in fur
blankets and finishing in shirt sleeves
he wrote four rousing tingling rapturous
pleasure
there is no holiday trip that approaches
the bird flight down the Himalayas in a
handcar and he later judged that
February day in India the single most
enjoyable day of his entire trip so
Twain visited South Africa and then he
went on to London to write his travel
book in seclusion and the New York
Herald almost ten months later on June
1st 1897
in a piece headline Mark Twain ill and
London sad news about the great humorous
mental and physical collapse he had had
a checkered career so a rival paper the
New York Journal sent a telegram to a
young reporter and it stated if Twain
dying in poverty London send five
hundred words if Twain has died in
poverty send a thousand so the reporter
reached Twain's house on June 1st 1897
Twain refused to be interviewed but he
scribbled a reply that it was his cousin
James Ross Clemens who was ill and then
he wrote quote the report of my illness
grew out of his illness the report of my
death was an exaggeration so overtime
and retelling that is more to the
reports of my death are greatly
exaggerated
one of the most famous quotes ever and
that seems like a fitting spot to wind
this to a close
Twain lived in Europe for two more years
and made enough more money to pay off
his debts he made the money from his
travel book he came home in 1900 to a
hero's welcome banquets tributes Awards
his career and reputation revived
because he had done the amazing
international trip and because he had
paid off his debts a lot of businessmen
I would say hid behind bankruptcy laws
or use the courts he paid off his debts
and his complete edition started selling
his publisher gave him a huge contract
and he wrote to his daughter
I can stand considerable petting borne
so Jean well he got the petting man lots
of it and it's still happening thank you
very much
I know any questions any questions from
anybody some questions for the mic
anybody want to be on TV
yes you said he had a great marriage a
nice marriage I can't imagine I mean if
she was if she if she was an heiress and
he lost her money and she was trying to
make him behave all the time
that's a unique it's an unusual matter
you have to realize here is this man who
is unbelievably funny that saves you
from a lot of trouble I mean he was the
most entertaining man of the era so and
and also he pulled it out of the fire he
she ordered him in effect to do this
stand-up comedy tour to pay the debts
quickly he followed her orders he paid
off the debts and so there was a great
joy in that I have one other burning
question I know that that grants
biography he made enormous success
how could he he made he worked the
largest cheque in the history of US
publishing two checks one for 200,000
back when that was you know God knows 30
million or whatever the number is and
then another one for a hundred and fifty
thousand and yet Twain's company was so
mismanaged he did not he had a contract
written in that he had final say-so on
all books but was not allowed to be
asked to do anything I mean that's a
recipe for running a startup no so
thanks anyone else
okay what thank you very much appreciate
you coming now in the front of the store
and Richard Zacks we'll set up here and
sign copies of his book thanks for
coming